Who Gets the Royalties for Hitler's Book?
Mein Kampf, the autobiographical, anti-Semitic
hate-manifesto written by Adolf Hitler in
the 1920s is one of the most controversial
and infamous books of all time.
As you might imagine, this has resulted in
millions of copies of the book being sold
since Hitler did the world a major favour
and heroically (and with no regard for his
own personal safety) managed to infiltrate
the Führerbunker and take out one of the
most hated individuals of all time- himself-
in 1945.
So, ever since Hitler fired a Walther PPK
at his own head, who’s been collecting the
royalties from sales of the book, how much
did Hitler make off it before that, and why’d
he write it in the first place?
Hitler initially began dictating and drafting
the outline to Mein Kampf while imprisoned
in 1923 after a failed attempt to seize power
in Bavaria in a coup d’état which eventually
became known as the “Beer Hall Putsch“.
Conceived by Hitler as a way of simultaneously
spreading Nazi ideals and paying off the massive
debts he had racked up, the future-Fuhrer
realistically expected that his book would
only primarily appeal to those who were either
in or sympathetic to the National Socialist
Party.
For the most part, Hitler was right (a sentence
this author sincerely hopes is never taken
out of context in the future) and upon its
release in 1925, it sold a modest 9000 copies,
nevertheless earning him a nice little income.
Mein_Kampf Over the next few years, as Hitler’s
star rose in German politics, sales of his
book similarly increased.
Legitimate sales of the book peaked in 1933
(the year Hitler became Chancellor of Germany)
with a reported 850,000 copies being sold
that year.
(In total, it’s estimated that around 10
million copies of the book were sold during
Hitler’s lifetime.)
Padding these totals significantly, when Hitler
became Führer (“leader/guide”), millions
of copies of the book were purchased by the
German government and were distributed for
“free” to German soldiers and newly married
couples.
In doing this, Hitler ensured that he earned
royalties for every one of the “free”
books handed out by the government by declaring
that local authorities had to pay to cover
the book’s cost before giving them away.
It’s difficult to determine exactly how
much Hitler earned from all these sales, but
according to the documentary, Hitler’s Money,
the total rang in at just under eight million
Reichsmarks.
Equally difficult, for a variety of reasons,
is converting that amount to modern day dollars
or pounds.
But, as an extremely rough estimate, eight
million Reichsmarks in the early 1940s would
be equivalent to around $30 million at that
time or about $430 million (£279 million)
today.
Whatever the case, given Hitler’s fairly
lavish lifestyle in the immediate years leading
up to (and then later including) his time
as leader of Germany, and with most of his
personal income coming from the book sales
in the early going, it would seem his bank
account was doing alright.
Of course, we should note that this doesn’t
take into account all of the money Hitler
later acquired through various other means
such as a licensing his image to the German
government (earning him money every time they
sold a stamp or other item with his face on
it).
Hitler also maximized his personal income
by simply not bothering to pay his taxes.
This created something of a problem for him
initially, but he managed to string along
the German tax office for years, at one point
brashly claiming that he only owned “one
desk and two bookshelves“, while simultaneously
driving around in a brand new Mercedes.
At other times he kept the tax officials at
bay by insisting he’d pay off his tax bill
in installments over time.
This all culminated in Hitler receiving a
tax bill of 405,500 Reichsmarks shortly after
he became Chancellor in 1933.
(For reference, the average annual teacher’s
salary in Germany at the time was a little
under 5,000 Riechsmarks.)
Still not wanting to pay his taxes and now
being in charge, he promptly had a representative
of the ministry of finance declare that the
Führer was “free of tax obligations”
and the massive tax debt he’d accumulated
was waived, along with future taxes he’d
have otherwise owed.
While sales of Mein Kampf internationally
were decidedly more modest, Hitler still made
considerable amounts of money from them before
the start of WW2, with it being noted that
he made somewhere in the region of “$500,000
inflation adjusted dollars” from sales of
the book in the UK alone.
As Hitler was officially a resident of Munich
upon his death, the Bavarian government seized
all of his property, including the rights
to the book and immediately outlawed its publication
in Germany.
Despite this, the book is still published
and sold with some success in other European
countries and beyond today where it is not
banned.
As the legal copyright holder, Bavaria is
entitled to any royalties from such sales
and they do accept them, albeit begrudgingly
before giving them to charity.
That said, when Hitler died his will instructed
that any objects of “sentimental value or
necessary for the maintenance of a modest
simple life” be split amongst his living
relatives and friends, while his art collection
and remaining assets be split between an art
gallery in his hometown of Linz and the National
Socialist German Workers Party respectively.
However, the Bavarian government decided to
ignore this will as part of what we like to
dub their commendable “screw Hitler initiative”,
taking full ownership of his entire estate.
While legally some of Hitler’s distant heirs
could lay claim to what remains of Hitler’s
estate (which is still estimated to be worth
millions), none of them are willing to do
so.
(In fact, apart from not wanting anything
to do with Hitler’s estate, the sons of
Hitler’s nephew have even gone so far as
to agree to never have children to end his
bloodline.)
While rights to Mein Kampf belong to the Bavarian
government throughout most of the world, in
the UK and the US, things are a little different.
In the UK, rights to the book belonged to
Hurst & Blackett, who purchased rights to
publish a translated version of the book from
Hitler’s publisher in 1933.
When Hitler died, Hurst & Blackett retained
the rights and continue to sell copies of
it to this day, though now under the name
Random House (a publisher which bought them
out in 1998).
However, the company, unwilling to profit
from a work of Hitler’s, has for some time
gifted all royalties made from the book to
an anonymous charity.
In 2001, it was revealed that the charity
in question was The German Welfare Council.
That council then stated that they were planning
to return £250,000 of the £500,000 they’d
received over the years via book royalty donations.
This came as a response to the controversy
that erupted to their ever having accepted
such funds and being confronted by various
prominent individuals, including the chairman
of the Holocaust Educational Trust, who felt
that profiting in any way from such book was
inherently wrong, even if the money was being
used for good.
The £250,000 they’d already used from the
sales of the book had been given to aid Holocaust
survivors.
The Welfare Council stated of all this,
When we agreed [in 1976] to the arrangement
the generally accepted view was that there
was a moral obligation to pass the money to
Holocaust victims – but no Jewish charity
would take it.
The current board of trustees, however, has
decided the funding is no longer appropriate
– not least because we no longer deal exclusively
with Holocaust victims.
This charity was chosen because of its work
with Jewish refugees from Germany, but their
number has diminished greatly over the years;
most have died of old age.
The problem now is that no one wants anything
to do with the money.
Upon learning that the Welfare Council would
be returning the money, Random House decided
that they would distribute the unwanted funds
and any subsequent royalties to “another
appropriate charity“.
As to why the German Welfare Council had so
much remaining from the donated book royalties,
it was explained that, “We kept it in a
separate bank account from other donations
and used it only in emergencies.
Holocaust victims who were helped by the charity
may not have known about the donation and
I fear that some might be offended.”
In America, royalties to Mein Kampf are collected
by Houghton Mifflin, who bought the rights
to the book from Hitler’s publisher in 1933.
Interestingly, at least two other publishers
(Stackpole and Reynal & Hitchcock) are known
to have published unlicensed translations
of the book in the 1930s by arguing that because
Hitler self-identified as a “Stateless German”
his book wasn’t copyrightable.
Neither of these publishers paid any royalties
to Hitler; in fact, Stackpole advertised the
book by explicitly stating Hitler wasn’t
getting anything from the sales of their version.
At the start of WW2, the American government
seized all profits and rights to the book
within the country.
The government then held the rights to Mein
Kampf until 1979.
During this span, they made about $139,000
in royalties, with this money placed into
the War Claims Fund before being paid out
to victims of the war.
In 1979, Houghton Mifflin paid the US government
$37,254 to quietly buy back the rights earning
them an estimated $700,000 in royalties over
the next two decades.
However, when it emerged that the company
had been making hundreds of thousands of dollars
from sales of the book, they issued a statement
stating that the royalties the book earned
would be distributed to charities that promoted
“diversity and cross-cultural understanding”
and a host of other things Hitler would have
hated.
The Red Cross (founded by Henry Dunant with
the intent to prevent and alleviate human
suffering, without discrimination, see: A
Memory of Solferino – The Fascinating Life
of Henry Dunant) was one candidate for receiving
royalties from the U.S. sales, but, like so
many more before them, the organization reportedly
declined the money.
Thanks to German Copyright law, Mein Kampf
is scheduled to enter the public domain on
the 1st of January, 2016 meaning there will
likely be even more arguments and controversy
about who, if anyone, should profit from Hitler’s
hymnal of hate.